Real data is often quite messy.
There are many possible issues with
real datasets such as bad formatting,
trailing spaces, duplicates, empty rows, synonyms
of different abbreviations, difference in scales,
inconsistency in description, skewed distributions
and outliers, and missing values. Each of these
issues can cause problems in data analysis and
deserves attention in exploratory data analysis.
There's substantial evidence
that data errors are widespread.
In clinical research, the error rates
are reported to be between 2.3% to 26.9%.
Sometimes, a seemingly minor mistake can cause
serious consequences. In 1999, NASA lost a $125M
Mars orbiter because an engineering team failed to
convert measurements from English to metric units.
Data exploration is often the
first step in data analysis.
It involves summarizing and realizing the data
set. It should be done before any modeling work.
In addition to the detrimental consequences of
data errors as mentioned before, massive data
can also cause modern issues. As an example, a
modern approach can fail if it encounters a long
numerical value for a numerical variable. This is
a case for the common yield regression analysis.
Also, analysis done on massive data can suffer
from the commonly known effect of garbage in,
garbage out. In other words, data analysis
done on faulty data can often be misleading.
Data exploration serves several purposes. First,
it helps gain intuition about the data. Sometimes,
this is called data understanding. Such intuition
can be quite useful in subsequent data analysis.
And they may even dictate an appropriate
choice of modeling techniques or tools.
Second, it helps conduct sanity checks on the
data to ensure that a data looks reasonable,
in the right format and on the right scale.
Third, it helps find out whether there are
missing values outliers. Finally, it is common
to summarize the data in data exploration.
These includes both the numeric
summary and data exploration.
How should we perform data exploration? The
simplest way is to manually review the data.
For those of you who have experienced working with
spreadsheets, you may have manually reviewed data
in the past. However, manually reviewing data is
labor intensive and not feasible. Even an Excel
spreadsheet can have as many 1 million rows. There
are several ways to explore large datasets. The
first, is to examine samples of data. By working
on samples of data we can directly interact with
the raw data even for large datasets, which can
greatly help us to gain some sense on the data.
In the end, however, we need to summarize the data
either using numerical summary or data validation.